oh you're also good yeah
okay welcome to this morning's session
on quantum supremacy the the speaker for
this session is Adam Boland a good
friend of mine and collaborator and
he'll tell us about the mathematics of
the of the foundations of the quantum
supremacy experiment thanks for showing
up for the first talk of the day I
really appreciate that so today I'm
going to tell you I have a chance to
give a two-hour kind of introduction to
the mathematics of qualm supremacy
experiments so the starting point for
this talk is really Google's 2019
supremacy claim and what's really
interesting about this experiment that
you may have seen in the New York Times
or something like this is that you can
think of it as being the first
experiment that ever occurred in
complexity theory you don't really think
of complexity theory of being this kind
of abstract mathematical topic that
maybe it's not that connected to the
real world but this is an example where
this kind of physical reality came
crashing into computational complexity
and why do I say that well what their
claim is is they what they claimed to
have achieved it's quantum supremacy and
what this means
I'll just define it it's a practical
demonstration of a quantum computation
that's prohibitively hard to reproduce
with classical computers
okay so why is that kind of such a big
deal
well you can kind of see the importance
of qualm supremacy from two different
perspectives so the first perspective is
that this is a claim to be an
experimental violation of the extended
church-turing thesis so whenever you
take and enter the theory of computation
class well the first things you learn is
that kind of very simple computational
models like you know finite automata or
cellular automata or
Turing machines are in some sense very
general models for the computation that
occurs in the physical world and we've
known since the mid-90s that quantum
computers can challenge this ect in
theory like what the invention of say
Shor's algorithm but we've never seen
that challenge kind of implemented in
the physical world so you can see klom
supremacy as being a kind of an
empirical violation of the extended
church-turing thesis the second way that
you can kind of see the importance of
this task is you can see that it's a
it's kind of a test of physics and high
complexity regime so once again you know
Shor's algorithm tells us that quantum
mechanics has this kind of very high
complexity regime that you know systems
of n particles require to to the end
parameters to describe them and and in
some sense a qualm supremacy experiment
is kind of some sort of proof that you
actually need that exponential number of
parameters in order to describe your
quantum state so this this exponentially
is kind of intrinsic so you can kind of
view this as through an experimental
physics lens as well well of course the
cheating supremacy is really difficult
because it required it kind of
intrinsically requires the computational
complexity theorists who normally live
out here in theory land and the
experimentalist to kind of meet in the
middle so the reason is that you need to
find you need some well-defined
computational task
which has two properties first it has to
be experimentally feasible then the
second is that it has to have strong
evidence for intractability and when I
say strong evidence for intractability I
mean it in the complexity theory
accent's we'd like some sort of complex
etheric evidence that there is no
classical algorithm that could have
mimicked this experimental quantum
device alright and moreover there's
actually a third property that we'd
really like which is we've liked some
method of verifying this experiment and
you can see that these properties are
almost immediately in tension with one
another because if you have a task
that's kind of intractable furling
you'll the world's biggest supercomputer
or something like that then that how on
earth could you check that your phone
device is working properly because by
definition you could not have simulated
it so these challenges are kind of
interlinked and today what I'm going to
do is I'm going to give you kind of a
history of the theory mostly behind the
second and third parts of this of course
this this the fear the story of the
theoretical foundations of supremacy is
of course intertwined with the
experiments as well but I'm going to be
focusing on the mathematical foundations
for hardness and kind of in the first
talk right now so in in this first talk
I'm going to be covering kind of the
complexity theoretic foundations of all
of these experiments and then the second
talk I'll be talking a little more in
the next talk I'll be talking a little
more specifically about Google's
experiment great so let's let's dive in
all right so what's the starting point
for trying to give complexity theoretic
evidence for hardness for quantum
computers you can you can see this this
second thing actually from kind of pure
complexity theoretic standpoint so you
can actually see this as just asking
well let's just ask more generally kind
of what's our evidence that that beep
that bqp is not equal to B P P little R
evidence for this you know we have kind
of Shor's algorithm which solves some
problem that we don't know how to solve
with classical computers but in some
sense there's nothing that goes
complexity theoretically wrong if Shor's
algorithm
you know if factoring isn't P in fact
this this could actually be be the case
so we're yeah so today we're going to be
looking at this more from a just a
complexity theory perspective and you
know the usual story in complexity
theory when you're trying to separate
two classes is you want to find kind of
some difference between the classes like
even it might even be a miniscule
difference to start with and then try
and see if you can kind of use that as a
wedge to to separate the classes and
kind of like you're effectively
identifying a weakness in one of the
classes that you can exploit and so the
starting point for the story about
separating bqp and BPP is going to be
about the difference between two
somewhat obscure complexity earth
classes gap p and the class sharp p so
sharp p maybe most people have heard of
if you take in a complexity class gap p
your you might now be loading up the
complexities easier to look at what this
is so let me remind you what these two
classes are
so sharp P Sharpie is a class of
functional problems and the complete
problem is really easy to state it's
basically what's the complexity of
computing exponential sums so the
complete problem is you're given some
boolean function app mapping from 0 1 to
the n to 0 1 and your goal is to compute
how many times f evaluates to 1 so
you're trying to compute the sum over x
+ 0 1 to the n of f of X and this is in
general not something that's you know
computationally tractable because this
is an exponentially large sudden that
you have to perform but nevertheless you
know you can think of this as you know
just some sort of abstractly the finding
counting class now at P the definition
of gap P looks almost exactly the same
as this definition here you're given
you're given some function f which maps
from 0 1 to the N to the set plus 1 and
minus 1 and your goal is to compute the
same sub sure
okay great so let's look at these two
classes so what's the difference between
them you know they look almost exactly
identical but the only thing that
changed between gapi and sharpey is in
gap P we added minus signs right and
then sharpie we just had zeros and ones
okay so what what's what what's the big
deal so you know okay so what what why
is this an interesting difference well
it turns out that this is basically a
difference between classical and quantum
reticular sharp P is in some sense a
classical class and gap P is in some
sense a quantum class so what do I mean
by this if you have a classical
randomized algorithms
then computing the probability that it
accepts
this is is actually sharp P complete so
sharpie and some sets exactly captures
the difficulty of computing say output
probabilities of randomized classical
algorithms now on the other hand if you
have a quantum algorithm then computing
the probability that quantum algorithm
accepts
is gapi complete
and the proof of this is really simple
the proof of this is like you know the
simplest quantum algorithm you can
imagine let's say you have some function
f and you want to encode this this sub
in the output probability of equivalent
circuit all you do is you perform the
following circuit you take 0 to the N
you have them are that you compute F as
a phase Oracle superposition and you
have them are that again and you can
very easily check that what happens in
this circuit is that the output the
probability that this outputs the string
0 to the N is precisely this sum right
here the reason you're getting pluses
and minus signs is because of kind of
the interference that's occurring in the
quantum device because this this
Hadamard is you know Fourier transform
actually more generally the output
probabilities of these circuits are
effectively the either the Fourier
coefficients of that ok great so that's
good so you know we started out with
this goal of trying to find some
difference between B QP and B P P so we
we found the difference so how can we
leverage this to try to say that there
in some sense different classes yes
correct correct yes so the question was
or yeah the comment was basically you're
not actually computing this output
probability with the circuit that that's
absolutely correct rather this output
probability is somehow encoded by the
circuit so just this mathematically so
there's no sense in which sampling from
this circuit or performing this circuit
is Ghat P Hart rather the output
probabilities of the circuit encode some
some hard functions and the hardness of
those functions is different than the
same the same quantity considered for
classical circuits
okay so yes I I'm that's exactly where
I'm going to next at the moment I'm
talking about exact yes great so what's
the difference between these classes
okay so let's look at the differences
between Gabby and Sharpie well in some
sense they're actually very similar
classes the reasons that they're
actually equal to one other under Turing
reductions you know the proof of this is
really simple you know right you know if
you want to solve a gap P problem you
can solve this with two calls to a
sharpie Oracle you just first compute
the number of ones in the sub and then
you compute the number of minus ones and
the sum and then you subtract them or
maybe another way to put it is that if
you take your gap P function f and you
just add one to every output now it's
domain is you know now it's range is 0-2
now this is a sharp piece of so you know
by it you can compute the sharp piece
sub and then add two to the end or
something like this in order to so that
looks like bad news for us
yokas are we making a mountain out of a
molehill there like this seems like a
pretty subtle
you know difference of complexity
theoretic flavors here between them but
there's one difference which is
precisely what was just asked as a
question which is that they have very
different behavior when it comes to
hardness of approximating them
namely let's consider the problem of
multiplicative approximations to these
sums so let's call a a C multiplicative
approximation to the sum to be a number
X such that X is multiplicatively
approximates the sum
sorry maybe not okay and you can then
ask how hard is it to compute
multiplicative approximations to get P
functions versus sharp P functions okay
and here the complexities are start to
become quite different
alright so if you look at gap P
functions constant multiplicative
approximations of gap P functions
they remain gappy hardened so in other
words you you don't lose any hardness
when you go to the to the to the
approximate setting when you consider
ghat peak and the proof of this is
extremely simple the proof of this is
basically by a really simple padding
argument so all you do is you say okay
so a multiplicative approximation for a
gap p function in particular gets the
sign of the sub correct right this is
just kind of by this definition so the
way that you you can use an
approximation to the sum to compute the
sum exactly is by some form of padding
with binary search so all you have to do
is giving your function f kind of Pat it
with some extra one arguments like let's
say it's originally initially negative
you can't Pat it with some extra
arguments that evaluate to one and do
that until it kind of crosses the point
where it switches from a negative sum to
a positive sum and then kind of go from
there and and and binary search so
okay so that's what happens - that's
what happens to gat P under under
multiplicative hardness reductions its
gappy hard under under Turing reductions
yes yes and actually because because gat
P and sharp P are the same under Turing
reductions you know you can just yeah so
so you know saying it's Gabby hardliner
Turing reductions and sharpey hard under
Turing reductions are the same thing
yeah well what's going to happen with
sharp P is going to be something quite
different so sharp P it's actually
becomes easier under multiplicative
approximation in particular a there is a
famous result of stockmeyer from the 90s
which says that you can achieve a 1 over
polynomial multiplicative approximation
to sharp P in the Class B P P to the N P
so this is like randomized computation
when you where you give yourself an
Oracle for solving 3sat now once again
that first glance you know at first
glance this might look a bit weird you
know in each of these cases you know
actually computing these approximations
you know would require exponential time
classical computer but actually the
point is that structurally these classes
are quite different in fact there is
kind of a well-known fact and complexity
theory which is they basically that B P
P to the N P is not equal to two gap P
well it's it's not equal to say it's a P
to the GAT feet unless something called
the polynomial hierarchy collapses this
is a consequence of Tobi's theorem your
polynomial hierarchy is just some
generalization of the belief that p is
not equal to NP so what this is saying
is that there's you know time based on
very standard complexity theory
assumptions there is a fundamental
difference so the hardness of
approximating sums of positive things
and the hardness of approximating sums
of positive and negative things so I
think that this is the complexity
theoretic formulation of what physicists
call the signed problem of quantum
mechanics so the sign problem arises
when you're trying to view the partition
function which is some exponential sum
and when there are huge amounts of
cancellations in the sub it's really
hard to estimate it with say Monte Carlo
techniques and on the other hand sums of
positive things are much easier to
estimate this is kind of the complexity
or other kind of formalization of that
statement of the sine problem and so
that's good so we we started with our
initial observation that bqp and BPP
look a little bit different you know
this gap fever sharpie and once we go to
approximation now this has kind of
leveraged up that difference into
something that seems a bit more
substantial in concrete and the
beautiful fact is that this is this
difference is already enough to start to
argue about the intractability of
simulating certain quantum experiments
all right so are there any questions
about this this first bit get any easier
if you restrict these sums to be
positive it seems like the reduction you
know it that it's it's hard to just know
the sign of the sum so suppose I promise
that some turns out to be positive oh
that's a great question
if you promise the sum is positive it
might still be hard if you give yourself
a strong enough approximation multiple
but I'm not sure off the top of my head
yeah okay great
okay so I'll move on so the interesting
fact is that this is already enough to
to give you some difference between B Q
some form of b QP and some for a b PP
but in order to do this we have to
perform a kind of relaxation of our
problem it turns out that it's really
helpful to think about the complexity of
reproducing sampling problems so what's
a sampling problem you're given some
input X and your goal is to output a
probability to a sample from a
probability distribution
it's called D of X okay so this is kind
of a relaxation of the sorts of problems
we normally think about in complexity we
normally think about say decision
problems or functional problems but it
turns out that making this relaxation
really helps you a lot with trying to
argue about complexity theory the card
yes and the analogy that's been given
here by Scott and Alex I believe is that
you know thinking about sampling
problems it's kind of you can see the
quest to show hardness for qualm
computers by Shor's algorithm kind of
like trying to demonstrate chimpanzees
intelligence by teaching it to play
chess all right so it's true that if you
take a chimpanzee and you put it through
a rigorous training program you could
probably get the place of rudimentary
form of chess okay maybe maybe checkers
say but it's kind of that's kind of
really difficult and that's not what
actually kind of behavioral scientists
do when they study animal intelligence
they more go out until the animals
native environment that you know observe
the chimpanzee uses tools or something
like this and it's natural behavior and
that's kind of the way you look for you
know to demonstrate the intelligence of
chimpanzees you can think of the move
from decision the sampling problems of
this exact same sort of statement and
the reason is that you know quantum
computers you know qua mechanics
intrinsically produces random outputs so
in some sense sampling tasks are the
natural thing that quantum computers
just do anyways that they just do
naturally so in some sense by moving the
sampling problems you're looking at
computers kind of on their native turf
kind of in their natural environment and
this kind of change of mindset has
really borne fruit so it turns out this
was kind of the the first results kind
of in these qualms supremacy arguments
the if this ideas goes it goes back to
Tara Hollander Vincenzo but it was maybe
a little
it was stayed in a language closer to
this language in work at Brenda Joe's a
shepherd in there it's a
which is that this is already enough to
argue that to argue that classical
computers cannot sample exactly sample
from the same probability distributions
as quantum computers
and the proof of this is kind of really
simple so what do I mean by exactly
sample from the same probability
distribution as quantum computers so
let's say that you have some quantum
circuit see
and it defined some distribution DFC
then the statement is something like
there's no classical algorithm that does
the following thing that given as input
see
it outputs a probability distribution
you know D prime such that this D prime
is month is a multiplicative
approximation of DFC such that for all
outputs X and 0 1 to the N if the prime
of C and D prime of X is a
multiplicative approximation of D of X
so note that the nature of this result
it's kind of a worst-case result and
it's also a a multiplicative result so
it's worst case in the sense that this
argument tells you there's no classical
sampler that does this task for all
circuits alright and the second thing is
that it's allowing some form of
multiplicative error so it's saying that
the classical the demand on the
classical sampler is it has to get every
single output probability of that
circuit correct with only this tiny
amount of multiplicative error so this
is a very stringent requirement on the
classical sampler but it's kind of very
easy to see given these facts without
gap P and sharp P it's it's easy to see
why this is the case and the basic idea
is something like this the basic idea is
that if you the the the proof of this
fact is that something like by way of
contradiction so let's suppose by way of
contradiction that there exists this
classical sampling algorithm a
okay then let's look at the output
probabilities of the sampler well
they're they're multiplicative
approximations of the correct thing and
those multiplicative approximations are
harder than they should be for a
classical circuit so the kind of
punchline is that you're gonna say show
that if there's a classical sampler a
then there's a too good to be true
algorithm or you know for
multiplicatively estimating the output
probabilities of the ideal quantum
circuit
right and in particular you know the
too-good-to-be-true algorithm is a B P P
to the NP algorithm you know if we have
a classical sampler we can estimates
output probabilities and B P P to the N
P on the other hand the output
probabilities of the quantum circuit
yeah okay then this would then
multiplicatively estimate the output
probabilities of the classical circuit
which is itself a multiplicative
estimation of the quantum circuits so
putting those two multiplicative
estimates together it would give you a
multiplicative estimate of the output
probability of the quantum circuit and
that's that we know is that we know is
gap P hardened and we know B P P to the
N P is not equal to gap P therefore this
algorithm is too good to be true so
that's kind of the the basic statement
that you're able to get just kind of
from this initial observation and yeah I
should mention that these original
results didn't phrase it exactly in this
language but I think this is maybe the
way to retrospectively look at them and
see that they were all doing the same
thing and this is this is kind of that
at the core of this so now what's really
nice about these results here is that
they actually are very widely applicable
to a huge number of different types of
quantum circuits and particularly if
they're widely applicable to even very
weak forms of quantum circuits as
quantum circuits which are not even
themselves capable of say universal
quantum computation right so for example
you can even show hardness of the source
sampling for quantum for circuits which
have all commuting gates so all the
quantum gates commute with one another
you can show it for linear optical
systems you can even show it to some
modified forms of clippard circuits
or something called conjugate Clifford
circuits which are basically Clifford
circuits where you perform a one qubit
change-of-basis so these are all circuit
families that look extremely weak and it
was kind of these early results that
started getting people excited well you
okay these very weak forms of quantum
sampling experiments you know look like
something that's a little more
experimental II feasible than building a
universal quantum computer so it was
these results that kind of helped launch
the field of bomb supremacy experiments
okay but exactly so these yeah there is
a the technical tools is a post-election
our events and we're in order to take
you back to the kind of the universal
case and then you then have Gabby
hardness but yeah that's fundamentally
what's happening in all of them okay any
other questions
okay so the next move was kind of you
know let's reflect a lobe on what we did
we found the difference between bpp and
bqp
we leveraged it up now we got that
there's no classical algorithm that
samples from the distribution of all
circuits almost exactly okay so let's
just progress but there's kind of a
still a lot to be desired here so what
are the drawbacks of these results well
the same we'll want to say what what are
some kind of obvious drawbacks of these
hardness of sampling arguments yeah
exactly
so the first drawback is that it's a
form of worst-case hardness so if you
want to demonstrate this in the lab
you'd have to literally show your qualms
computer could sample from every single
circuit that you could throw at it so
you would really like an average case
statement so that you know you have some
hard distribution to test against kind
of like in cryptography so okay good yes
what other drawbacks are there it's oh
yeah it's asymptotic yes that's right
so that's going to be a drawback of all
of the complexity theory XD heads we
could say but though that's totally fair
though yeah because you know yeah
eventually someone's going to do this in
a lab and then they're going to say that
for this finite system size we did
something interesting and yeah it's it's
very hard to say things with complexity
theory but what other drawbacks are
there for this
yeah yeah the multiplicative thing the
thing is that this multiplicative error
is very stringent it basically requires
you to do it to do your a qualm
experiment exactly right because each of
these quantum problems each of these
probabilities is of order like 1 over 2
to the N where n say the number of
qubits in your system and that's a
really tiny number and this saying you
get them multiplicative really correct
is saying you get each of them correct
you know almost exactly spot-on and on
the other hand if you add reasonable
amounts of noise to qualm systems you
end up getting added of errors in the
output probabilities like say until the
variation distance error that's what you
naturally get out of even fault
tolerances it naturally gives you
additive errors and not put not
multiplicative errors so it's not
experimentally realistic because it's
it's it's it's too exacting on the
experimentalist okay so yes yes yes
great great yes you also have a
verification problem the test I told you
is hard is to sample from this output
probability distribution but how can you
even empirically check you did that like
if it's a distribution that's on the
domain of size 2 to the N right so you
would need exponentially may samples to
even make an empirical guess as to what
your device's distribution is yeah well
what we'll get back to this exact yes
and also to figure out what is the ideal
output probability as well yeah so
they're they're they're two
Exponential's at that plate here okay
great now it turns out that there's a
way of trying to mitigate these
drawbacks and the solution is actually
to move to average-case complexity this
ends up actually helping you with the
noise as well and with verification and
that somewhat not obvious entirely
obvious why why why this would work but
I'll try to give you some some intuition
here so this was kind of the next kind
of step on the quest towards supremacy
and this was in Aronson arkhipov paper
and the basic idea was to try to move
these results to average case hardness
to deal with the noise but it will also
fix this other drawback as well and
what's the basic idea well the basic
idea is that you can make a kind of more
general form of the stockmeyer reduction
and in particular you can you can make
something like this
so in fact I'm just going to draw this
on a different board so that I have a
little
interesting point
sure sure okay so what's the okay what
was the love of Arizona market Hobbs
insight well it's that this stockmeyer
reduction is a little bit more general
so in particular you can view it as a
reduction from having an approximate
average case classical sampler
to having an approximate average case
algorithm or computing output
probabilities
so this is the all right so let me
explain a little bit what I mean by the
words in these bubbles only because my
handwriting is atrocious
but because but making these things more
precise I think will give more will give
more insight here so in particular what
this reduction does is it starts with an
average case approximate sampler and
here the notion is something like this
like given an average case quantum
circuit see what this algorithm does is
it outputs a sample from some
distribution D prime of C such that the
total variation distance between D prime
of C and the ideal distribution of the
quantum circuit is say less or equal to
Epsilon ok and now this type of error is
starting to look a little more
reasonable this is because kind of the
errors I affirm quantum systems kind of
naturally give you an additive errors to
your to your to your in in terms of
total variation distance to your output
probability distribution this is no
longer as exacting on the
experimentalist we're giving them a bit
of wiggle room some of the individual
proud output probabilities here could be
totally off like there's there's no no
requirement each one of them is pinned
down but the interesting point is that
if you have a sampler like like that's
of this form then there is some
statement you can make which is which
says that basically most of the output
probabilities of D prime of C
are mostly correct so what do I mean by
that well if you have a distribution
that's close in total variation distance
to another distribution let's consider
the error that that kind of the
difference between the two distributions
on each individual output stream well
because there's total error epsilon and
there are 2 to the N output strings okay
if the average amount of error per
string is going to be roughly epsilon
over 2 to the N so mostly correct means
to additive error
epsilon over 2 to the N this order you
know by putting a constant there you
know you can just use a Markov
inequality you know that 99% of them are
less than 100 times the average amount
of error okay
and the stockmeyer reduction actually
but ends up giving you is it ends up
give you an algorithm to compute these
output probabilities to this amount of
error right so in particular at the
algorithm on this side of production is
an algorithm which you know given an
average case C it computes a quality
i'll call p 0c pzr OC is actually and
maybe in my forum notation should be if
you consider the distribution DFC what's
the probability it outputs 0 so this is
my notation py FC is the probability
that quantum circuit C outputs y
all right so here the the algorithm is
given average KC you compute the output
probability to additive error epsilon
over 2 to the N you know with high
probability over the choice of C so this
is an algorithm it doesn't work all the
time but it just works on average so
most of the time it gives you a solution
that's close to the right answer all
right and what this means is that if you
conjecture that this task is hard then
this object cannot exist so that's kind
of the the fundamental inside of this
reduction so what this this reduction
tells you is that if you want to argue
about the hardness of sampling
approximately then the way to do it is
to shift and start talking about the
hardness of estimating output
probabilities on average right so what
this means is that yes yes yes so this
reduction works for a family of
distribution on circuits the way I've
written it there is a mild requirement
on the family of distribution circuits
which is that it's kind of symmetric
between exchanging output strings in the
distribution yeah that's because I just
wrote this in terms of talking about you
know one fixed output string 0 to the N
but if I put four randoms why here then
that that condition would not be there
yeah yeah it is
yeah that's right doesn't his argument
work for other distances that's a great
yeah this is this argument is really
specific to total variation distance
actually yeah that's a great question
good any other questions about
okay so what's okay so what what what
does this mean well if you look at this
reduction it means that if you make the
following conjecture so the following
conjecture implies hardness of
approximate average case sampling and
what's this conjecture the conjecture
states that for this distribution over
circuits I haven't specified that yet I
will start plugging and distribution
soon the basic conjecture is that it is
it's a sharp p or gap p hard to to
compute the output probabilities
approximately and this is to say this
means to additive error some epsilon
over 2 to the N and on average this
means something like with high
probability over the choice of C
okay so if you make this conjecture this
is an approximate average case hardness
conjecture this is kind of a superpower
conjecture this gives you the ability to
this gives you the ability to argue that
there's not even approximate Sandler's
this is precisely what you want okay so
the natural question is okay great you
you can make this conjecture but have
you just kind of just conjectured what
you needed for your theorem and and not
really done any complexity theory I like
work here like what what justification
do we actually have that this conjecture
is true for any distributions this is
kind of you know we we not only add an
error we also move to the average case
here you know average case hardness is
all about what distribution you picked
you know some distributions are easy
usually and some distributions are hard
so the kind of key insight of Aaronson
arkhipov was that there actually there
exists some distributions over quantum
circuits actually there will be even of
restricted subclass of closed circuits
such that you know this conjecture is in
some sense reasonable or it has some
kind of reasonable so that like there is
a reason to believe that this average
case hardness conjecture and the basic
reason is that what they showed that
they claim is but what they actually
proved as they proved its sharp be hard
to exactly compute
0c on average over some distribution
uncie in fact the way that they did this
was was really beautiful
what they did is that they considered is
that they considered some form of
experiments which are called linear
optical experiments and these have the
special property that the out their
output probabilities correspond to the
permanence of randomly chosen matrices
it turns out the correct the
distribution on matrices ends up being
the the Gaussian distribution and 0 1 to
the N by N
and this is a really nice statement
because permanents are a very
well-studied object in classical
complexity theory
so it turns out that it's been known
since work of Lipton in the late 80s
early 90s which basically showed that
the permanent is hard is actually sharp
be hard to compute on average over the
choice of matrix a which is from
permanence over a it's randomly chosen
from per matrices over a finite field FQ
okay and what Eretz on arkhipov did is
they basically provide an extension of
this to the they provide extension of s
to the gaussian ensemble so what does
this mean for kind of complexity like
what does this mean for this conjecture
well what this effectively means is that
you can kind of think of the support for
this conjecture for boson sampling in
the following way so let's make a table
of kind of hardness results so here I'm
going to describe
I'm going to describe the type of error
here so these will miss Merrow will be
exact hardness results and this will be
approximate hardness results and this on
the other hand will be worst-case
hardness and this will be average case
hardness so this difference between gap
P and sharp P they talked about this was
establishing that computing these output
probabilities are these are hard to
approximate in the worst case so the
this is asked at P for sharp P tissue
this comes up here this is because of
cancellations oh this square is like the
freebie this square is even there in
classical sampler so this is this is
like the free spot in your your bingo
board okay and then what eret arkhipov
showed is that there are distribution
there are circuits where you know
average case exact targets so what's
happening here is that you know all you
need to do it's kind of fill in the
missing the missing box so you somehow
need to provide some find some way of
combining you know the best of both
worlds because we know that there's
average case hardness for its
distribution but it's exact we also know
there's worst-case approximate hardness
all you need to do is to somehow combine
these proofs in in order to prove the
statement which is then you know it
gives you this very rigorous complexity
theory right justification of possible
okay now of course the difficulty here
is that this box is really difficult to
fill in it's actually open for all fun
of supremacy proposals to date so this
actually remains open for the boson
sampling experiment for the Google
experiment at any experiment that you
can think of but the fact that there's
average case hardness here and and some
form there's some form of approximate
hardness and some form of average case
hardness gives you some hope to believe
that this might be true and now I also
want to make another kind of
philosophical statement which is kind of
what part of this table is the quantum
part okay like what part of this table
could we only get with a quantum
sampling problem
now the classical one and the answer is
it's basically well it's basically this
row so this row this row here is the
uniquely quantum because you know our
intuition for why there is there could
be approximate hardness is coming from
these cancellations we actually know of
examples of problems where things
classical problems where things are
exact average case hard but they come
very easy when you move to approximation
so I'll give you an example so let's say
that you consider a matrix let's say
that you draw a matrix a from you know
some distribution on some distribution
on our plus and by n so that's to say
imagine that I draw a matrix a such that
all of its entries are non-negative say
no that turns out then it turns out that
the techniques are used to show exact
average case hardness carry through so
the exact computation a permanent of a
is still sharp be hard but somewhat
surprisingly the approximate computation
is super easy actually turns out to be
in BPP this is a result of jerem
Sinclair and Vigoda that you can
actually there there's an FP path for
approximating for approximating
permanence of matrices that have all
non-negative entries so in some sense
what this is saying that really our our
hope for this hardness statement is
really resting on these cancellations
that's really kind of the intuition that
that is present in the complexity theory
for why this approximate average case
hardness conjecture might remain true
all right so great so are there any
questions about the state of affairs
yeah
intuition as to why that case is so hard
is there some intuition as to why it's
so hard to prove well the intuition is
basically that our proof techniques for
proving exact average case hardness
really are not noise colorant at all and
actually at the start of the next talk
I'm going to go through a this kind of
exact average case hardness proof may
right before I talk about the Google
experiment and we'll see there exactly
why it's it's very not noise for bus
so I'd say lack of techniques is the
reason why there's why it's been so so
challenging to resolve this and any
other questions Oh
lack of techniques it's true if it's not
true yes that's right yeah yeah yeah yes
yes Scott so yeah if it's not true then
that that would be a problem as well
that's you this this or the sampling as
a whole so well I I would say that there
have been works I have been trying to
push this this sort of thing a bit
further right where you can find some
distributions with hat which have you
know some amount of cancellation but are
still easy to approximate in Algar so
for instance there was a result of of
Eldar neck Rabanne i think that was in
2018 but they basically showed that
there's a quasi pali algorithm
or computing the permanence of matrices
where they're not drawn from the mean
zero Gaussian but they're drawn from
gaussians which have a positive mean so
they're biased towards the positive
direction but in the obese these still
have substantial amounts of negative
numbers in them as well so yeah so there
have been some attempts to do this there
was also a recent work of Knapp la placa
Dalzell hero and brandão from this year
like showed basically something somewhat
similar for for the quantum circuit case
I'll describe that in more detail after
I describe the Google experiment but
they also provide some example of some
distribution over circuits where you
have exact average case hardness but not
approximate average case tartness so
yeah I guess so those have been the
works that I've been trying to push from
the other side to try the see well to
whether you know yeah you sure the first
proof probe a little bit whether you
think the conjectures are true as well
right it's worth thinking on both sides
okay great yes okay so I'll conclude
this first talk you know what did we do
we started with this really obscure
thing about gat P and sharpey and we
managed to bring it down all the way to
something that looks like almost
experimentally feasible like all you now
need as an approximate average case
sampler that but you know we had the pay
to get there first and we paid the piper
by making this approximate average case
conjecture that we don't know how to
prove but at least we're able to support
it and so this was kind of the picture
of what the complexity theoretic
arguments for qualm supremacy looked
like in 2016 and in the next talk I'm
going to explain to you kind of what
happened since then and particularly
what happened with the Google experiment
alright thanks for your time
[Applause]